Adam Sandler big-time celebrity got a
new movie out the week of with Chris
Rock got to see it last night had a
cameo with myself and the dance and
Sandman how are you
you want to know where I lived
all through NYU what apartment yes
the Jefferson I lived in the Jefferson's
Department the whole time I went to NYU
we'd be on Jefferson yeah I live with
George and Weezie they never left and I
and nobody but nobody knows offered up
today hold on I'm trying to digest that
that the sand man lived with the
Jefferson so Weezy would make you dinner
and I was on the Upper East Side with
the Jefferson yeah we didn't always make
that no the movie was a lot of fun you
know Congrats on that a lot of work went
into that but a little bit emotional
their little sandman bringing up some
emotion there some tears and then that's
wives well given your daughter you're
gonna do this though twice with your
daughter's man you're gonna have now
will that resemble you think in any way
your daughter's weddings yeah yeah maybe
maybe I think so I think so I'm good
only to definitely have a hard time
saying bye that's gonna be awful that's
gonna be awful even sending them off to
college hurts right yeah right Danny yes
it does yes it does thankful yeah ankle
well one of them I wanted to see go 3 3
4 I missed the other one I was like you
know I saw you a handsome boy last night
he came he came to the party man he
looks incredible Jack yeah he crashed
the party
hey can I go to the party and I go yeah
I guess yes he goes why I know those
guys I worked on the movie and I go well
then call somebody you know and then he
just shows up with his girlfriend so
thanks for letting me man hee hee hee he
was such a the abusive behavior he
pulled last night screaming at my work I
was on this movie I was like no you
worked on a movie for for movies ago
he's like no you don't you don't get the
typical romantic interest like you do I
love how you position like you know
Aniston or Beals or you know you've
always got Selma Hayek I mean you're
you're always messing somebody in there
well done yes yeah but not your family
man I'm a family man I am married to the
great Rachel Dratch we Chris Rock enjoys
running around in the boat he still
enjoys the ladies company and and his
son is marrying my daughter were in our
two families who were I'm kind of middle
class and first it has a lot of cash and
I'm trying to put on the best wedding
possible to impress impress everybody
and you did a great job you did you did
you did some job coaching my kid in the
movie and you were and you and I'm
honored to have in it and and the
dinettes walk beautifully didn't yeah it
was it was quick but they did get their
cameo there so that was it was greatly
appreciated there and I heard that some
of the Danites were negotiating for a
new movie last night that there's a
movie overseas from what we're hearing
that could be in Monaco or in Italy
Sandman can you confirm or deny okay so
we start shooting in Canada and then we
eventually and I'm working out
everything I'm going to do do all I can
to bring all of the guys there and then
once that happens I have to buy you a
car that's it that's the only negative
how hard I'm trying this one time why
you will be a very very strong American
mobile and then we'll go from there
we'll go over there but I tell is that
believe me I'm all over this I'm gonna
try to make get this done I I feel bad
though that I you know I sort of
reminded you last night of the car with
the next movie and I I had a couple of
drinks in me so I that's not fair to
your very generous but it'd be certainly
great to have a car though
Sandman for all all of the effort that
I've yeah I do
i I don't I don't have a car but I build
an empire how much have we made at the
boss box-office seriously in me what 16
wheel here yeah
how much over the if I if I put it all
together I would say probably about four
or five hundred million dollars but
getting you a car makes sense to me
believe me Danny I've seen you ride the
bike around town no no I I guess I get
that you fool you're frugal and I like
when you tell people the reason I ride a
bike is I had a DW I don't have a
license I believe me I'd be in a car if
I did and tell people about this stand
up that you're filming your stand-up
routine and I think you got Wednesday
and Thursday you're doing again work I'm
gonna be into work Wednesday and
Thursday I can't wait get the whole
giant camera crew is gonna issue Sandman
and the Sandman's audience hi everybody
please come on out and enjoy the year
the evenings and yeah I was I was in
North Carolina in Cincinnati and
Milwaukee and Columbus and I've been all
over
I've been all over everybody show them
all it's been incredible and when is
this going to be on then Virginia oh my
god they not forget Virginia I it'll
probably come out next September next
September I thought it was unsure but in
that neighborhood so we got to put it
together and all that but man it's been
fun it's been fun doing stand up again
has been incredible love it the we
of Adam Sandler Chris Rock and you can
see it on Netflix I believe starting
this Friday so a SAN medic thank you
hey it was great seeing you safe travels
and we'll talk soon and then your wife
looks great too loves to walk
Thank You salmon there you go four more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]